and take a look at this will show you
how fast this has happened since the
first case in the US was discovered way
back on January 21st we are now well
over three hundred and thirty thousand
cases that is close to one in a thousand
Americans and even that may be a low
estimate nowhere is the crisis more
evident than right here in New York City
where hospitals are overwhelmed our lead
national correspondent David beg note
was invited into one of them in Brooklyn
a lot of our patients are presenting
with severe respiratory distress and
it's a very acute they were fine and
they had some call and then they weren't
fine
dr. Joshua Rosenberg is a critical care
doctor who also specializes in
infectious diseases at Brooklyn Hospital
Center can you tell me of anybody in
here right now who is one of those cases
like no underlying conditions right here
is a patient that really didn't have
much underlying conditions as developed
severe respiratory failure as well as
kidney damage from the virus and is
relatively young that's about where it
is right now the hold is this gentleman
this gentleman is I believe in his early
50s they put him on a breathing tube and
you know to save his life and he's
requiring pretty much 100% oxygen and
he's requiring a lot of air to help keep
his lungs inflated it doesn't get any
more critical than this it does not the
majority of this hospitals patients are
on Medicaid or Medicare there were ten
other patients in the ICU
most of them black men all on
ventilators unconscious and isolated
behind glass they're all positive for
coronavirus what do you gentlemen want
people to know well I think people
should take it seriously I think you
know initially it was advertised as
something that affected only older
patients and that's definitely not
something that we're seeing we're seeing
a lot of younger healthier patients and
they're coming in in a very
full state we wanted to hear from nurses
give us your real-life assessment of
what you're dealing with here it's very
very difficult it's like something out
of The Twilight Zone and I don't think
any of us going through it will ever be
to say this is Kay she asked us not to
use her full name because she fears
getting threats from patients family
members who were not allowed to visit
I'd like a mask like yours I'd like all
of us that have mass like yours and
these white suits like you have and I
have it what do I have what is it looks
like a garbage bag kay was not the only
staff member wearing a garbage bag over
her scrubs
many people use sanitizing wipes to
clean themselves as they were this woman
works as an endoscopy tech but since
elective procedures have been canceled
in New York State she's been helping out
an ICU many of her colleagues have
fallen ill it happened to her twice did
you have Kovac I what I have the
symptoms um I had two chairs I had a
headache I didn't have the fever but I
had the chills I had a headache
I had a shaking I heard the call for any
constant korfin under-budget your
appetite your desire I can eat you're
teasing my mouth and he went for went
out came back and I was getting
shortness of breath and I went out again
so I just came back Wow
Reznik Wow before we left dr. Rosenberg
went into the room of the man in his 50s
who suddenly needed his breathing tube
changed for that Rosenberg put on a
replaceable gown and ski goggles as he
went in to join the team they were
successful this is serious people are
dying from this old people young people
people are dying from this it is lethal
27 Kovac patients have died so far at
that Brooklyn Hospital and every time it
happens the body is loaded into the back
of a tractor trailer which is parked
outside
you heard nurse Kaye ask for the face
shield that I was born
she has I gave mine to her we sanitized
it and delivered it to her over the
weekend she will go to work better
prepared today than she walked out on
Friday
CBS News has a very limited supply which
we are using to bring you stories like
these and her asking for that shield is
a reminder that nurses here in New York
City and for that matter everywhere
around the country are asking for better
protective equipment
[Music]
yeah and they should get a David doing
incredible work there and what Kate
called the twilight zone thanks David